月曜日はちよっと鬱です。
はじめしゃちょーです。
というわけで今日で
ポルトガル語の授業が終わりました。
というわけで来週はポルトガル語のテストで
ま、実質僕の大学生活のシメとなるのは
ポルトガル語のテストです。
ポルトガル語と他の授業の単位をしっかり取っていれば
ひとまず大学は卒業でございます。
はぁ、ついに卒業か、俺も。
頑張りますよ。
ついに卒業だよ、俺も。
やばいよ。はじめさん卒業だよ、大学もう。
何か、こう、大学が終わるなっていう、ちょっと実感が出てきております。
今日はちょっと真面目なおはなはなしをします。
噛んだ。
今日はちょっと真面目なお話をします。
今ちょっと、マクドナルドさんがねぇ、何か変なのをしてて・・・
えっとねぇ、名前募集バーガーというハンバーガーを売っているみたいです。
一部の店舗でね。
売っているらしくて
僕それちょっと食べたいなと思って、たまたまゲットできたんですよ、今日。
やべ大丈夫？うわっ、真っ白だ、すごい
パッケージが真っ白なんですけど、こちらです。
北海道産ほくほくポテトとチェダーチーズに
焦がし醤油風味の特製オニオンソースが効いた
ジューシービーフバーガーという名前が
仮についているみたいなんですけども、
ちなみに明日からですね。
2月2日からマクドナルドのどこのお店でも
買えるらしいです。
北海道産ほくほくポテトとチェダーチーズに
焦がしシュウミ醤油の特製オニオンソースが効いた
ジューシーバーガーなんですけども、
ちょっと長すぎるので、
新しい名前を募集しているらしいです。
で、それが2月2日から
名前募集スタートで、
この名前募集バーガーの名前を
応募して、
その名前のハンバーガーに
これがなった人は、
ハンバーガー10年分
ゲットできるみたいです。
名前募集バーガー10年分相当の賞金
これが390円で、
390×365日
×10年分で、
142万3500円をプレゼントらしいです。
やるしかねぇ！
やるしかねぇぞお前ら。
このハンバーガーの名前を当てた奴には、
142万円貰えるんだ。
やるしかねぇだろ
あのー
ガチで賞金取りにいきます。
俺もうガチで賞金取りにいくからね。
ぜってぇ当てる。
ハンバーガー1年分プレゼントとかも
僕ちょっと当たってるんで、
あるんすよ。運もあるし。
ネーミングセンスもあるから、
俺ならきっと当たるんすよ。
俺もちょっと詳しいことは知らないんですけど、
この名前募集バーガー、とりあえず買ってみたんで
ちょっと食べてみましょう。
「Open the Price」！
おー
あー、なんか
こんな感じです。
わっ、ポテトが入ってる。
ポテトとお肉が入ってますね。
チェダーチーズも入ってるのか
チェダーチーズ、入ってた。
あーなんか香りはすごいいいですね。
これを実際に食べて名前を決めなきゃいけないんだ。
142万円の賞金を手に入れる運命的な瞬間をね、
ちょっと見せようと思います。
同じ名前で応募があったときは抽選になるらしいんで
あんまりこう、言ったらだめじゃね？
言ったらみんな俺のハンバーガーの名前にしたら、
みんなで抽選になるから、え、どうすればいいんだろう？
とりあえずちょっと食べてみてどんな味がするかを
ちょっと感じてみましょう。
いただきやす
んー、なるほどなるほど
オニオンソースがおいしいなぁ。
うまい、おいしい。
ポテトもちゃんとおいしいなぁ。
あーこれ、おいしい。
オニオンソースとポテトがすごいマッチしてます。
北海道産って感じでさぁ、
このなんか草原、大草原が頭に広がってくるんですよ。
この大草原が広がってきて、広ーい原っぱの真ん中に、
HIKAKINさんがいる感じです。
これの名前かぁ・・・
いや、たぶんね、間違いなく普通の名前だとダメなんですよ。
このインパクトに限る名前だと絶対受かんないし、
たぶん同じようなことを考えている奴らも
たくさんいるから、ダメなんだよ。
もっとこう、インパクトのね、もう
「ええ？！なにこれ？」
ぐらいのリアクションになるような名前をつけないと、たぶん、
賞金142万円は手に入らないと思います。
かといって俺がここでね、バッとこの名前にしますって言うと、
みんな真似しちゃうと、俺たちでそのさ、
抽選になっちゃうから、
何個かちょっと、候補を挙げときます。
その中から俺はたぶんね、名前をいれるよ。
候補三つぐらい考えました。
いや、普通の名前はダメっしょ、まてまて。
これ難しいな。
北海道の感じがすごいからなぁ・・・
とりあえず一つ目考えました。一つ目は、
「ちんちんバーガー」です。
これは特にハンバーガー関係なく、
もうインパクトだけを求めた名前ですね。
目に留まれればいいな、ぐらいの感じで
一個は「ちんちんバーガー」。
だめだたぶん。
やべ、「ちんちんバーガー」しか思い浮かばない。
これじゃただの中学生だ。
ええー、なんだろ
ちょっと瀬戸さんの動画見よ。
瀬戸さん：ポテトバーガーです。でもそんなレベルだよね。
ポテトバーガーか。
(笑)
瀬戸さん：絶対受かんねぇわ。
難しいんだよ、マジで。本当に難しい。
瀬戸さん：はい、それではですね、
瀬戸さん：次はチョコポテトなんですけれども、
チョコはお菓子だから食べれないんだよ
ちくしょー瀬戸さーん！
ポテトバーガーか、そういう手もあるなぁ。
(笑)
あああっ
オニポテ、オニｐ・・・
「オニポテチーズバーガー」
ちょっと普通かな・・・
まぁでも一応候補として挙げておきましょう。
「ちんちんバーガー」と「オニポテ・・・
チーズバーガー」。
忘れちゃった。
「オニポテチーズバーガー」か、「ちんちんバーガー」か。
もう一つなんかホントにインパクトのある奴ほしいなぁ。
結局ねぇいろんな物が入ってるから
難しいんすよねぇ。なんだろう。
「韋駄天春の・・・」
「ルキュース・メルギリュースバーガーGZX360丸」
「韋駄天東海道膝栗中トウ毛」
「光と闇の間に生まれしフレッシュネスバーガー」
いやこれ難しいよ。
はっ
そうだ。
「North of Guilty
雪原に生まれし光の作物のユートピア
DarkSide of フレッシュ of カレー」
あっカレーじゃねぇわ。
DarkSide of フレッシュネスバーガーとかでも
いいかもしれないですね。
難しいんですけど、ちょっともうちょっと考えて
応募してみます。
ただこれねぇ、あの他の人も応募しちゃうと
俺の当たる確率が減るから、
みんなは応募しなくていいよ。
ちょっとね、ホントちゃんとした奴を考えて
僕ちょっと143万円欲しいので、
ちょっと、頑張ってみようと思います。
というわけで名前募集バーガー、
2月2日火曜日から全国のマクドナルドで
売ってるみたいです。
よかったら食べてみてください。普通においしかったです。
じゃあな！